Summit yesterday and it comes as
president zelensky arrives here we're
expecting him to arrive here later today
and really this is a huge show of
strength from the G7 7 aligned with
Ukraine the Allies have been shoulder to
shoulder throughout this conflict so
providing support agreeing sanctions
trying to choke off Russia both
economically and then giving Ukraine the
Firepower to try and beat uh Putin on
the ground and these fighter jets then a
massively significant moment I should
say too though Anna that it could take
up to 18 months for these Jets to be
deployed because the fighter pilots will
need to be trained and then the Jets
sent over but there are a number of
European countries that have these Jets
Denmark have them Poland have them the
Netherlands have them Norway have them
the UK don't
um so this is a really significant
moment
um it will be a big moment too when
zelenski arrives here uh in Hiroshima uh
for further talks with European uh
leaders as well as of course the US and
as well as southern hemisphere countries
there are a number of other countries
here India Indonesia some place Brazil
uh countries some of whom have been a
bit more neutral on Ukraine stick in in
the middle or side in almost with China
and Russia so there's another push in
all of this Summit as well for the G7 to
try and bring some of the southern
hemisphere countries uh more to their
way of thinking